I can tell you on Cova door coronavirus
or whatever you want to call it plenty
of names tremendous progress is being
made if we stop testing right now would
have very few cases if any we've also
gotten better on testing so that
explains a little bit but in with these
increases bill we're seeing increases in
hospitalization and that's a real
concern the president is absolutely
disinclined to shut down the economy as
is the Vice President I agree with mr.
Kudlow and the White House that we don't
want to shut down again the question
isn't do we want to shut down the
question is can we get a control of the
virus that is the question and here we
go again focusing on Cova because their
cases are increasing obviously there's
more testing nationwide but as you look
at the numbers here at the u.s. 2.1
million cases but a 116 thousand deaths
globally or at 7.9 almost 8 million
cases 434 thousand deaths the president
meantime looking at the disparity in
coverage and tweeting out the far-left
fake news media which had no kovat
problem with the rioters and looters
destroying democrat run cities is trying
to Kovan shame us on our big rallies
won't work and they are moving forward
with that rally in Tulsa Oklahoma let's
bring in our panel Fox News senior
political analyst Brit Hume mara liason
national political correspondent of
National Public Radio and Chris Starr
Walt politics editor here at Fox News
Brit we are seeing an increase of cases
we always point out that there is more
testing the president pointed that out
too
but the experts are concerned about a
resurgence of Kovach what I'd say about
that bread is that some experts are
concerned and we're seeing increases in
some places and others the decline
continues the larger question as was
touched
by a couple in those couple of the sound
bytes is what we do about the cases that
are turning up now some as a result of
course of cases being discovered by
testing some obviously new infections is
whether we're going to go back to
lockdown in some places I don't think
there's any appetite for it politically
and unless we knew more about who is
being infected and how seriously and
whether they're going to recover you
can't really make a case for for
resuming lockdowns in places where
they've been eased I just don't think
that makes any sense at all yeah I mean
to your point bred and this is back to
you the University of Washington and
they have adjusted their predictions and
expectations they're now projecting 201
thousand deaths by October and that's an
increase of 18 percent but we've tracked
this throughout here well but brently
the University of Washington model has
been off time and time and time again it
is something of a modern miracle that
all of us seem to pay so much attention
to that model it's just a computer
projection those things are often often
these have been wildly off so what they
say now I don't think you know counts
for anything Maura what about the what
the president talks about the disparity
in coverage not really a big problem
with all the protests or the health
experts weighing in but yet when it
comes to the Trump rally in Oklahoma you
know it's night and day well
health experts will say that going out
in a big crowd is a bad idea whether
you're protesting or you're going to a
trump rally but you know Trump is going
ahead with this rally he clearly has
taken some precautions I think people
are going to be tested for temperature
they have to sign a waiver that if they
get sick after they go to it they get
Kovan they're not going to sue the Trump
campaign so this is a tricky problem
look what Britt said is right if you
test a lot of people the numbers are
going to go up and the president kind of
doesn't like that on the other hand if
you test a lot of people then you can
tell people who have symptoms to stay
home and the other ones are fine going
to work and you have a better handle on
the problem in general is the president
Chris Wright to point out that despair
in coverage you know NBC had these two
tweets within an hour about one was a
protest where just noted though how many
people were there and the other one was
a tweet about the dire warnings about
the Trump rally to come within one hour
of each other we're focused on obviously
the the facts on where the corona virus
is but clearly there is a different
level of coverage well he can complain
about that or even complain about the
weather or he can complain about
anything else you can't change it's not
like NBC News tomorrow is gonna wake up
and say man this Donald Trump is on the
ball we really like this guy the
question comes as we look at Saturday's
rally can they execute it in a way that
is reassuring and competent competency
is what matters here they're gonna hand
out masks will people wear the masks
there's no public health official
anywhere in the world who would say that
Jam and 18,000 people inside of one
enclosed space is a good idea under this
so they're already taking a chance can
they execute it in a way that looks
competent reasonable and responsible as
would be fit somebody seeking a second
term in office yo Bruce right now go
ahead oh I'm sorry I was just gonna say
the smartest thing the president could
do could be the movies rally outside
that would immunize it seems to me from
criticism since when all the protesters
are outside in huge numbers and a lot of
the same people that complained about
the Quran Tobias fell silent so as far
as for the race Fighting's ahead he's
been ahead he's like to remain ahead for
a while that doesn't mean that when it
gets down to it you'll win but in my
view he certainly ahead how big a margin
they've been a couple of polls it made a
double-digit I think we wait to see if
those are duplicated in the next round
of polling to decide whether we believe
that or not ya know as we've said we're
still a long way out I want to turn
topics here and this is the president on
John Bolton's upcoming book Mara I want
you get you react to what he said to
them it was advised very strongly not to
write it until it's cleared and he
couldn't wait and we'll see what happens
but I think he's got personally I would
imagine his crew like
when you do classified
that to me is a very strong criminal
problem and he knows he's got classified
information any conversation with me is
less but then it becomes even worse if
he lies about the conversation which I
understand he might have in some cases
so we'll see what happens you know
obviously the white house seems like
it's still going to fight this yeah it's
good they're gonna fight this Bolton's
lawyer is adamant that there's no
classified information in it that he
followed all the procedures that he
presented the book for review at the
National Security Council I think
starting in December and there's going
to be a big fight about this but they're
determined to go forward what's
interesting is there have been a lot of
books written by former Trump officials
none of them as high-ranking as John
Bolton and none of them as we understand
it to be as potentially negative right
Chris but he did not testify during the
impeachment proceedings or anywhere
around there and now it's book time
well maybe bolt will get really lucky
and they'll try to put him in jail and
he can sell a million more bucks as the
great martyr of this stuff you know when
you have when you have a tell-all when
you have one of these kiss-and-tell
numbers that come out they want maximum
controversy I have no idea what's in
Bolton's book but the White House and
the president sure doing a good job
helping him sell copies right now